d.c you grew up in west oakland
california yes
yeah i grew up in west oakland i grew up
uh
i grew up in 70s in the 70s well i came
of age in the 70s in
west oakland california my mother lived
there my father lived in vallejo
california which is about 30 minute
drive away
and uh yeah they they split up when i
was about five years old
and but my father was always present in
my life he would come see us every
weekend or pick us up every weekend so i
almost had two homes growing up
i'd be like living in vallejo on the
weekends and i'd be living with my
mother
during the weekday and it was very
supportive
and nurturing environment i have uh one
brother
and two sisters did you go to marine
world uh yeah
in vallejo you know about it oh yeah
well when i grew up in vallejo there was
no marine world
yeah there wasn't one at that time it
was just like uh it was like just a back
um woody area with a pond you know it
was
dan minnie park is what it was called
right and so we would go there as kids
and we'd fish
and we would play we had a tree house
there it was like great
it was just like this expansive land and
then um
when i got to high school they built
marine world and then we'd wake up in
the morning we'd hear dolphins
and we'd hear you know the seagulls and
all that stuff because i lived literally
um maybe about five minutes oh wow that
close
okay yeah well you said you had
supported parents even though
you were you were going back and forth
but you said that a lot of kids that you
knew
growing up in west oakland their lives
weren't like that yeah yeah for a lot of
kids uh especially my like my friend
my best friend terry for a lot of years
i never saw his father
and um so i just assumed you know i
didn't know where he was but his father
was in prison
right and that was the reality for a lot
of kids growing up in west side oakland
either they were on drugs
and i'm not say all of them but i just
wasn't present to a lot of kids that had
fathers in the home
and uh yeah for reasons that i mean we
can get into
you know black men growing up in oakland
you know endangered species and all that
but
uh yeah so but i had a father he was
always stable he was always in my life
and then sometimes my friends would envy
that
right and what i saw my father do and i
think i have that trait now
he would extend himself to those kids
sometimes he would give my friends
allowances
right and sometimes if we were going
somewhere he would say hey ask
such and such to come along so he became
sort of this
father figure for a lot of kids growing
up in the neighborhood
and i say that my connection to that
because as i start to look at my own
life growing up
and the work i'm doing in sierra leone
the soccer tournaments i have the
relationship i have with the children
over there and the child minors
and just my relationship with children
in general i kind of see that
i think i got that from my father yeah
wow that's that's interesting that's
interesting that the kids
that you felt that that even at such a
young age that they knew like
i don't have a father present and you do
and yeah yeah and if i
was and you know there could be a little
bit of shame involved with that like
terry didn't tell me his father was in
prison
and then his father would come out and
we'd be playing and all of a sudden
you know it'd be like 12 and then i
wouldn't see his father for another four
years
and then i wouldn't see him for another
year and then we would see him when we
were in high school and then we'd work
out at the gym and each other's
this workout at the park and we'd be
doing nothing but the bars and we're
doing a strong little workout
i said wow your father's really strong
you know he's engaged with doing this
workout
you know um enough to me that he was in
prison a lot of that time and so he came
out it was sort of a
you know he was making connection back
with his son and i was getting to meet
him but
my friend never told me he was in prison
you see
yeah so uh
yeah i mean i could say more on that but
uh i guess and so in some senses growing
up in west oakland also
i was my mother and father protected me
from a lot also
like uh i just you know there was this
side there's this thing about west
oakland where you could live here but
then if you go
and you this is this was true up in
harlem a few years ago not now but
you could live here but then you go one
block over and it's like you know
it's drug infested and it's crack and
there's this and that
and so but my mother always kept me and
my father always kept me on this side
so i never veered i could never veer
over there you know and not because of
fear of them but i think it's just
because they um
they just instilled in me some really
strong values
growing up and they set a good example
like my father said a really good
example of
you know what to be as a man and uh
similarly with my mother also
right i remember when crack was was kind
of like becoming a thing oh yeah
and so i remember people would always
ask for like 10 like because a rock was
around like 10
or something there was always a story
centered around ten dollars
oh yeah because i grew up in the bay
area too and it was the same thing you
crossed one
part in it was much different and so i
remember this one girl had this
elaborate story and i wanted to believe
her
but because she said the ten dollar part
i was like you know what i i
they the kids at school had said oh that
the rocks cost
one rock was ten dollars and see what
you alluded to now see that's when kids
know too much too fast it's like this
generation right now with the media
you know back then you could be living
in the hood and yes you would be exposed
to things that you shouldn't really know
about
crack weed prostitution you know because
we were living right off of san pablo
san pablo wasn't that far
so you could see prostitutes you know uh
sometimes during the day
um and so that's when the young kids um
you get to be tampering with their minds
and you're giving them too much
information to you
they're losing their innocence if you
will and so i think my mother and father
tried to protect my innocence for as
long as possible
but i saw kids a lot younger than me
that had lost their innocence a lot
earlier
yeah poverty would do that to you too
you know quick then you start knowing
like for me i never knew where
food came from or that we were ever like
didn't have money
you know but when you're poor you know
you don't have money or somebody's gonna
have a conversation in the house around
you know we don't have this we have to
get food stamps or
you know emt yeah right or or also to
how the parents
of the other kids treat you um if
you if if you're aware enough and you
can tell well
yeah i'm sorry you can't come to the
birthday party yeah or there may not be
a birthday party
yeah right yeah there may not be a
birthday party you know so
yeah i guess so living in that
environment and being i guess growing up
at a level of
i don't know what that i'm using the
word empathy now because it just
it made me having what i had and it just
made me more
appreciative and it made me more just
really sensitive
about who other people were i was always
the kid wanting to help somebody out
i was always the kid wanting to go the
extra mile to make sure somebody's
feelings weren't hurt
and that was me that was me and my
family too so
if spike lee didn't make she's got to
have it would you be a filmmaker today
wow wow for you to ask that question
that is so poignant um because
it's likely that i wouldn't it is very
likely that i wouldn't
i knew that uh i wanted to help people i
knew i wanted a career that was going to
service my community
it was going to be around possibly
around black men
[Music]
you know and uh and what that looked
like i was all you know rights of
passage programs or whatever
but uh the film thing didn't become a
reality for me until i saw spike lee's
early work
and i think it has a lot to do with
modeling you know
um and we don't have a lot of you know
it's like
whether it's women men uh black men that
is
you you know there's something to be
said about representation
and modeling and at the time spike lee
came around there wasn't a lot of black
filmmakers
i mean that you knew about i mean it was
gordon parks he had done some work
uh the you know the shaft but i mean
there weren't and it was michael schultz
you know he did coulee high and but
these aren't films that like i would
i was really i loved the films but i
didn't know particularly if they were a
black man
but it was something about spike lee in
his signature work
when he was doing uh she's got to have
it he was doing
you know do the right thing and it was
just so pronounced
and so much of a signature around black
culture
that i was like this is what i want to
do so to answer your question
which is a really good question i don't
know if i would have been a filmmaker
maybe i think i owe my career
to spike lee i don't know if i'd have
been laying down that path
i don't yeah so it's really powerful i
mean he
had a profound effect on me in terms of
that
so you saw the film and then you decided
to go to college at
nyu tisch yeah yeah well i saw well i
was going back east i was first i was
going to university of massachusetts
and then uh i saw i had heard about him
making a movie
and then i saw the movie in new york
on my way to you know i was going to
umass amherst i drove cross country with
a friend
and i was just blown away and so going
into
going into umass amherst which is my
junior year i set the
intention i want to be a filmmaker so i
was gonna do whatever i had to do to be
a filmmaker so i started taking film
classes
i started studying film i started making
films like on film like 16 millimeter
boleks
and uh crank cameras and uh
and then uh i had decided i was going to
apply nyu
and i made a student film that got uh
i got a lot of awards at umass where i
was
and um and i applied to nyu because
despite me with nyu
and so that was sort of my my pulse and
my geiger my he was sort of my north
star
if you will you know so i and i was
reading all the books that he
had written at that time and so
i applied to nyu and i got in did you
ever get to meet him
i did i met him first year yeah i met
him the first year because he came to
the
he uh there was a woman named lisa jones
who had written his books
right she was his uh yeah she was his
his
collaborator on a lot of his film books
and she was at nyu and she was a few
years ahead of me
and she said spike's gonna and i heard
when i got this fight like to meet with
the black students right
he likes to meet with him you know the
first year and so he invited us all to
40 acres in a meal
his production company and i was like
just
you know i mean i'm star struck because
he was my idol
he is my idol he was my hero and i just
shook his hand
and uh yeah it's just you know what did
he say
um he didn't say much you know he was
just
i mean spike was he was a presence more
than anything else because he was really
back then he was soft-spoken and he let
his work speak
you know that was his thing and so for a
long time i was like wow how's this guy
doing this i mean because then the
business you got to be aggressive you
got to be strong
but spike is very disciplined he's very
focused you know you read his books he
would get up at 6 a.m in the morning
write him right he had a certain quote
he had to write on a screenplay
and for you know for the first like six
seven years he would do
a movie every year it would come out and
that was his process you'd wake up 6am
in the morning
you know write and they need to go about
doing this thing but so he's a very
disciplined
individual and yeah but i was just like
you know
well i was floored yeah it was lord he
was my hero
at what point did you know you wanted to
be a filmmaker i think immediately after
i saw
do the right thing yeah that was like
pivotal for me
and just creatively the way he put it
together and i didn't just want to be a
filmmaker i want to be a black filmmaker
i mean so that's the distinction i
wanted to make like i was aware of other
filmmakers out there
but i was strongly um
concerned about like representation of
black people and
you know what what that would mean for
for us
as a collective in terms of us needing
filmmakers to tell our stories
and so that became a very important
thing for me um
so yeah so i kind of um i embrace that
i embraced that and they used to have
conversations back then too you're a
filmmaker you're black filmmaker
filmmaker black i mean
we had a whole conversation at nyu where
people come in and actually say oh i'm
not a black actor i'm just an actor
i get that i do get that so yes i'm a
filmmaker i'm a diesel v filmmaker
and so i don't want to be marginalized
or i don't want to be you know
segregated over here
to this other classification but within
the larger context of being
a filmmaker i'm also an african-american
it's like being
a woman filmmaker right yes you're a
filmmaker we get that but within the
specifics of that
you're also a woman making movies right
and the reason i think you make those
kind of distinctions is because of
just the racism in society right and how
they
or the racism and the sexism and all
that and how they regulate regulated us
to a certain area so i but i took a lot
of pride in it
you know i take a lot of pride in it and
uh even today
you know i want to be a role model for
kids too and
uh so yeah i'm a filmmaker i'm a black
filmmaker i'm uh
yeah i'm a filmmaker who tells message
stories
message films yeah well that's funny
because you must be reading my mind
cause i was gonna go to the message part
and that is
did you see your parents uh be about a
cause
or especially growing up in the bay area
i know it's very cause driven up there
got the you know whole influence from
haight ashbury so
did you see that in them growing up
there what was interesting about my
generation is that
even though my mother was a black
panther i was very active
in that movement and my father had come
from the south
where clearly um and my father my father
had me at a later age
right and so he was born like 1921.
okay so he was coming from the south
clearly went through racism
segregation he had been called boy
you know uh you know he was he was
coming of age where there wasn't a lot
of opportunities for blacks so he
he ended up being a welder he was a
tradesman you know he became a welder
and he came out to california became a
welder
so you knew he was very well aware of
that
and when he would drive us home his home
to see his grandmother
in the south in alabama during the
summer's time
we would drive my father used to have a
gun in the car
a gun and it was on the side of the door
right
and so i'm like okay that's that's
already like why are we driving with a
gun and then when a white cop
would pull us over and this happened and
invariably it would happen
right he would get out my father was
very slow
in his motions he would get out very
slow
he would say yes officer no officer yes
officer was i speeding officer okay i
was speeding officer
okay like to see your license yes
officer you could show you my life he
was
very like overly um
congenial right and then he would get
out but now in retrospect you know he
was really
probably concerned about the safety of
his children and we were in arkansas or
we were in texas
and where you know something could
happen
right and so and because of his
background coming from the south which
he knew all too well
um you know this is how he behaved in
the presence of you know
of law enforcement if you will and so
but i say all that to say that so when i
came of age i think my father didn't
tell me much about that at all
like he didn't really and i know my
mother didn't tell me about the 60s and
the black panther movement either it was
later when i started going into college
and i saw a book laying around it was
huge newton's book blood in my eye and i
was like
mom what is this no it was george um
george jackson's
blood in my eye and i was like mom what
is this you know or hugh p newton's book
and
he had signed and autographed it for her
and then she would say oh yeah this is
blah blah
and but they tried to protect me from
that they did and my father tried to
protect me from all that
atrocities you seen that with a lot of i
think my generation that came of age was
like
they just didn't tell us about it as if
you know they were trying to protect us
so that we could
create our own futures and they didn't
want to harm us
because that was a very harmful period
in our history
yeah so i didn't grow up knowing much
about it wasn't until later that i would
start to investigate it
would you see your mom going to meetings
protesting no
no beyond that at that point it was
beyond that and so
yeah i didn't see that and she didn't
talk about it and my father didn't talk
about the south
and they never talked about it it was
only later when i went to college that i
would read
up on it and or when i read the
autobiography malcolm x
i remember and i was i'm so curious i
said dad blah blah you know about
mountains yeah i knew about him
he was in the north right but then he
wouldn't say much about him
you know and he just wouldn't he
wouldn't say much about him my mother
was the same way
they didn't talk about it like what
about cointelpro like did they
did they and my mother knew about
cointelpro and all that stuff but she
didn't talk about because
for them i think it was it was let's not
it wasn't about passing on that
information
because uh
it's weird now to think about it because
so we grew up
in sort of not a utopia but it's like we
didn't know about all that
that becomes this big schism between us
and i think in the jewish community you
don't necessarily always see that
because
they teach they keep teaching you know
the generations the holocaust becomes a
constant reminder and
you know you start going through bar
mitzvah and you know whether it's
the rights of passage programs they do
and it's like
here here's your information here's your
history whereas with us as
african-americans
sometimes it's like um we don't
some of us i don't say all of us but
that generational information is not
passed down
and so and i think because of the 60s
and turbulence of that and
what was happening in the south my
mother in them just didn't want to pass
it on and my friends didn't know about
it either
you know growing up in oakland but i
mean would it probably be no different
than basketball players now and you talk
talking about uh
you know not lou alcindor not kareem but
probably like
eldridge baylor and they're like well
who's that you know they may not have
that direct connection
to who he is in terms of history but
it's then during that time that i began
to see the connections to history and
why we must know our history
and how we empower ourselves through our
history yeah
and how that history can also determine
your future
right and so that's when i started to
make that connection with spike lee just
to bring that back home in terms of who
he was as a filmmaker
and then connecting that to you know how
we didn't have images
as black people or even so even the
images that we did have whether it was
coffee brown or some of the exploitation
movies we didn't direct
we did not direct them so it's like oh
okay so that's uh
i need to i need to change that your
first short film was in
1994 yeah it was called
notre dame key and i collaborated on
that was avery williams
and it was more like a mini feature it
was more like
uh i mean we were like because and i say
that because
avery i love him dearly he's in uh
atlanta right now he's teaching at
morehouse
but he wrote that script and he brought
it to me
uh to direct and i was like well you
know we're going to do this through the
school
and we sort of did it through the school
but we sort of didn't do the school we
kind of broke all the rules right we
used the school's equipment
um but we ended up uh
we we so we started the film process
there but then um
because of my earlier work i had gotten
the attention of disney hollywood
pictures
and they started this discretionary fund
program
and so they decided to give us forty
thousand dollars
to make that movie it was a period films
period film set in harlem
1947. and we had keith david in it we
had harry linux in it
you know both big actors right now and
so we were just young kids
just i mean just like fresh behind the
ears you know 21 22.
you know not really knowing a whole lot
what we're doing figuring it out as we
go
but just kept keeping it very
professional and um and that film went
on to win a lot of awards and get me a
lot of attention got both of us a lot of
attention
wow and forty thousand and ninety four
yes
yeah that's a lot that's a lot so it's
2019 now and you are just releasing your
first feature film
yeah yeah um i think the ad is about the
whole old adage about you know what's
holding you back
you it probably stands true and i think
for a lot of years i resisted
um writing right i became a better
writer over the years
but when i first started out i didn't
really particularly
write as much and i think that the
filmmakers that are really prolific or
the ones that really
uh can get there faster they generate
their own material
right and they write so it goes hand in
hand they write and they direct they
write near it so if you don't write
you're either having defined material or
work with other writers
right and so i didn't write for a lot of
years
and so when we look at the gap between
when i graduated film school when i came
out with my first feature
a lot of it is because um
i was learning how to write in that
period of time
yeah i was learning how to write were
you reading screenplay books
i was reading screenplay books but then
life happens
yeah you know and so i came out here uh
early 2000
um high hopes of directing
but it just didn't happen for me right
away it didn't happen i had to get a job
and so then i started looking at what
what are my options and then uh
i had always done sound in school i was
pretty good at doing sound as a
production
sound person in school so then i started
doing sound out in l.a
on commercials and videos and
so then what was it that made you want
to
do a feature film like why were you
ready
what is it two years ago yeah yeah well
time was getting away from me
you know and i i had figured that was my
dream you know i didn't want to get away
from my dream of being a director
and so i just hankered down and i did
whatever it took i just that was my
mantra i just decided i'm going to do
whatever it takes
and i'm going to confront myself at
every corner and so look at my
weaknesses and i make my weaknesses
into strengths and so then i just
started to write
and write and write and uh
and then then i hooked up with another
collaborator another uh
writer stephen pearson stephen palmer
peterson and he wrote skin in the game
and um yeah so were you
almost uh emulating spike lee getting up
at six i was getting up at six literally
i mean it's like even right now you know
like the cost
you know it takes a lot to be a
filmmaker and i think those that make it
other probably it's it's more
it's more determination and persistence
versus talent
a lot of times i mean talent hand in
hand you know
you know you take that for granted but
you want to be talented at it
but i think it's it's really about
persistence and determination
and how much you're willing to sacrifice
in some cases um yeah because in some
cases there it you know
you've got you may not be eating you
know you may be eating top ramen or you
may be taking
some least attractive jobs because it
allows you more time to write
right and i think this when i made that
decision and you're not leaning on other
people
in other words your the responsibility
for your life
and becoming a filmmaker is yours it
doesn't belong to your wife so your
partners or your boyfriends or your
mothers or your fathers
so it's not about them sponsoring you or
giving you a cushion or saying okay you
know what you go ahead and write here's
i'm gonna pay your rent for the next
couple months so it's it was about
taking complete responsibility
for for my dream and what i wanted to
make happen and what that looked like
and so yeah so if it met working all day
and writing all night then that's what i
did
was it about what 10 years ago you had
something that happened that your heart
stopped through
different times oh you've done your
research
uh i went 10 years ago i went to sierra
leone with isaiah washington
on a documentary film shoot and on that
shoot that shoot literally would change
my life uh not only did i get exposed to
sierra leone
and um the conditions over there because
they had just
undergone a civil war and isaiah was
looking up his roots and i was part of
the documentary team
i had a great experience but when i came
back i had a near-death experience
because i had cotton virus over there
called the hantavirus and
when i got back to l.a
i mean i was just i was just fatally ill
and i had to be rushed to the hospital i
was in the icu
and my heart stopped beating three times
i had
uh multiple organ failure and i was in
really bad shape and the doctors didn't
think i was gonna make it nobody thought
i was gonna make it so my mother at that
time flew up here
and uh people were just praying i mean i
was just in critical condition
and but miraculously i made it through
yeah i made it through did they know
what it was
they didn't at the time they didn't and
uh it was a good thing that i was at
what they called
uh was it danny freeman more hospital
and they were like oh thank god you
didn't go to
like cedar cyanide because the daniel
freeman hospital they could bring in
other technicians from everywhere like
hey brian people from ucla they could
bring in doctors from
usc to uh to help
on my case right whereas i've been
seaters they have like
clear rules about cedars-side doctors
working there and you can't bring others
in
but because i was at daniel freeman
hospital they were able to bring another
doctor so nobody knew what i had
all i knew was i had multiple organ
failure and my body was shutting down
and this one particular doctor stayed
with me and he had to restart my heart
three times in the middle of the night
and so yeah i know it looked like i was
on my deathbed
it looked like i was on my day and
actually i thought i was on my deathbed
too
the only thing kept me going was the
fact that because i
one morning at one point i remember
myself making um
sort of this uh resolve that like you
know what i'm gonna if i'm gonna die
my last moments were in africa my last
moments were playing with children
my last moments were with like you know
um having fun and sharing of my gifts
with everybody because that's where
that's what i was doing after
giving out soccer balls and i made some
serious relate some nice relationships
over there
so i said you know what if i gotta go
then so be it
i had made it i had made peace with it
you know and uh but it was another plan
for me
it was another plan i'm here and how
long were you in the hospital
i was there for about uh i was probably
there for about
seven to eight weeks total but for like
three weeks i was sedated
and i was under heavy sedation as the
doctors treated me and put me on
dialysis and we just
you know trying everything to fix me
trying everything to make me better but
nothing worked and they didn't know so
they said they just had to let it run
its course
and just let me be you know just let me
be
sort of get let my body fight it and uh
so yeah so then when you returned home
did you have any kind of like awakening
where like okay now
because i've been to this point where
most people haven't been there or they
end up oh yeah oh yeah things are going
to be different now oh yeah yeah yeah
much so that what happened was when i
got back
and i got well i shocked everybody
because i told my mother when to go back
to africa and she was like oh no you
can't go back to africa oh no you're not
going to do that to me again my mother's
beside herself
my father uh everybody tripped out i
mean they were like no you can't go back
because i got an opportunity to go back
with um was it regina king yeah regina
king
the actress had invited me to go back
and work with her on her documentary
and so they were like no you can't go
back you can't go away especially we
went back to sierra leone in the same
place
and so people were freaking out like
freaking out
and uh but i was resolved i was like you
know what i'm better
i can do this and i wanted to do this i
wanted to be there was some things that
had happened to me
by being sick you know like i was having
revelations around my life and what i
wanted to do with my life and
and how i wanted to show up and so
yeah and going back to africa was part
of it so even
in your like i mean when you were
conscious but laying in this bed or
whatever you knew
like yeah yeah if i got better i knew i
wanted to go back and i did go back and
um and not only did i go back i started
the foundation of an azer foundation not
only did i go back i had a
soccer tournament we would do every year
and we would put
kids through uh um school
we had foundation for that i mean i was
like i was working to get the kids out
of the diamond mines
i was very active still am mm-hmm
and did you finish that documentary
about the i did yeah in the document and
then
then i shot a documentary on it me going
back so the documentary captures me
going back
hosting the soccer tournament giving the
kids uh uh money for school
and giving a look at what the kids were
doing in the diamond mines
yeah and these are miners though these
are young miners like seven years old
14 muhammad and musa yeah i mean they're
older now but yeah
yeah and so that was a really powerful
thing for me and that actually started
the ball rolling with my film career
again
because once i did that documentary i
was just hungry and
wanted to do a feature right so then
what i did was
uh i wrote a feature based on my
experience
or rebirth experience about going to
africa and this trauma that i was
experiencing so it was sort of a true
life story although i
substituted myself for a football player
i made a little bit more commercial
and we spent i spent a lot of years
trying to get that going and i couldn't
get it going
and then after a number of years i just
thought you know i got it i got to work
on it because i couldn't raise the
financing
so i said let me work on a project that
i can do that's doable
something that um is uh it's not going
to cost a lot of money
and i just happened to be with oakland
at the time and then my sister was
talking about
uh how she wouldn't let her young
daughter ride the bus i said why don't
you let your
daughter ride the bus and why are you
driving around everywhere because that
wasn't my experience growing up
and she said with the gorilla pimps up
here and just recently there was a
gorilla pimp that snatched a girl off
the bus
and put her into prostitution i was like
whoa
really and so that stuck with me that
stuck with me and
in the midst of that i'm looking for my
next subject matter in terms of my film
then i came back up to oh came back up
to la and on the
newscast that the exact same week it was
talking about a young girl who was
prostituting herself
on long beach boulevard and i was like
oh wow so i just couldn't ignore
those two sort of circumstances or two
instances of
prostitution and trafficking that came
up and at the time i didn't know it was
called trafficking i was just like
prostitution prostitution it wasn't
until i would read it later that i would
say oh
they're the one in the same prostitution
trafficking these girls don't want to do
it
some of them are being manipulated
coerced you know
and that's how and i just started to
research it heavily and then um
started to think about what a film could
look like
i'm just curious do people notice that
you had changed in that you had gone
through
where you you faced death and then when
they saw you again
after maybe a year later they noticed
your personality was different or
and that you had a new sort of purpose
or
um i think the light had turned on
more i'm not gonna say it was completely
different i mean i was like
i was already like a very positive
optimistic person
wanting to do things but i was probably
stopping myself like
the tournament in africa and working
with the kids i never thought i could do
that
you know like there was something about
the way i was living life that i felt
like um
that was larger than what i could do
right and so i started to
so yes to answer your question once i
got better i started to test the
boundaries
more like around greatness enlargeness
and saying that i can do it i can do
that why not right and so
yeah in that way and then having to
experience death also i mean it just
gives you this sense of
i'm not saying immortality but you to
experience and be that close to death
and to know that it can be snapped away
from you that at an instant
it kind of sharpened my focus about
living life
in the present moment to moment and
doing as much as i can in that moment
and that was in 2009 yeah so do you
notice that
a trajectory of what you've done since
you like if you saw like a timeline yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yeah from the documentary to the the
trafficking movie the one skin in the
game we're going to talk about shortly
yeah yeah and then you know but along
that we just have to realize that it
just takes a lot to make it in film i
mean it's not like
maybe talking overnight successes 18
years you know somebody said oh yeah you
made it man
you're over and it's been working at it
for 12 years 13 years you know some
cases 20 years um
you know you never see a young morgan
freeman on the screen i mean like can
you imagine a young
what would a young morgan freeman look
like you know you've seen him in his 40
you know you see me when he did glory
and all that and he's already older he's
like i'm just like in his 40s but what
does a younger one look like
you know it's a lecture company you know
but so i so i say that to say that you
know
it was happening for me but nothing
happens overnight
and so it was just a lot of hard work
and um and a lot of dedication a lot of
time
did you think before that it was
possible to be this over like when you
were leaving tish
did you think you know what you know
i i cause i think people don't realize
sometimes
how how long it takes to get something
yeah i no
i mean if you told me when i graduated
that it was gonna take uh
15 years to do a feature i've been like
no i've been like you're kidding you
know you're out of your mind i would be
more like that right
and so no i mean i thought it was gonna
happen right away
and then i got uh you know i got hit in
the face with reality
filmmaking what it really takes and um
and
not only that but sometimes it just
takes a lot of luck it takes a lot of
being in the right place at the right
time
so and sometimes it just takes what it
takes
sometimes it just it took me like if i
had to say would i want to do any of it
over no
because you know if i had made it right
out of film
school i probably would have gone to
sierra leone right
i wouldn't have been gone i wouldn't
have been a sound man so i wouldn't have
gone over there with isaiah washington
i uh i wouldn't have um started a
foundation
so my life probably would have been on
another trajectory so i don't have any
regrets
it happened the way it happened i
embraced that
yeah and and um to answer your question
about just
being stronger yeah so the experience
made me stronger
and it challenged me to be better
with skin in the game what made that
project different from the other movies
that you had
gotten off the ground or been a part of
yeah skin in the game was probably one
of the hardest films
i had to make up to this point because
emotionally i had to take myself
emotionally
and in the writing i had to take myself
to a really dark place
right trafficking is a dark dark world
and so it was probably
it probably would have been my first
choice but i was
somehow compelled i was just compelled
to tell the story
after meeting the women talking to
survivors
i just got deeper and deeper and i just
said this is something i have to do
but um yeah but i think i probably
resisted it
at first only because of the the you
know the subject matter and the darkness
of it
but then at some point i just uh i
couldn't avoid it
as a filmmaker and as a human being i
mean i was just as a human being i felt
like i needed to tell the story i feel
like
the voice of these women needed to be
told
yeah and were some of the women that
i mean on set were they survivors of
this yeah oh
yeah we had one in particular her name
was jayla baxter uh there's another
woman named
deleta miller both survivors uh
both uh had been trafficked at some
point both um
were prostitutes escorts you know and
then they were on the other side of it
now they were now rescuing girls
right and they were in a leadership
position so they gave us a lot of
counsel
and i mean i leaned on them heavily in
the research of the movie
well terms you know the subject matter
you know i mean something jayla would
always say was
you know a young boy doesn't grow up
thinking he wants to be a pimp
you know so remember that in terms of
empathy
to everybody involved right and so you
know pimps have been grown
too you know a lot of times what i've
studied in the research not to give them
a pass
but i've found that um if you look at
their
backgrounds and the women sometimes that
are traffic they're equally the same you
know
no father abusive father molestation
right neglect um not feeling loved
yeah a lot of that stuff right and so
just empathy
i mean she just really jayla was just
really strong and talking about empathy
and she was really strong on talking
about boys and girls being trafficked it
was just girls it was boys too
so a lot of stuff i was hearing for the
first time like they were living it but
i was hearing it for the first time
you know and how did you meet them uh
well at first it was it was really hard
to get into the community
and when i say the community it's like
uh i was go to meetings
trafficking organization meetings but i
couldn't meet the girls
i couldn't meet survivors for obvious
reasons you know because
number one uh i'm a filmmaker so they
they're thinking oh exploitation
they could be thinking that you know
cash exploitation or what that could
mean
um and then i was an outsider i didn't
know anybody
and so then when i try to talk to some
of the girls
it's hard too because a male talking to
a young survivor could also be a trigger
for her
you know and when i say trigger that's
like a woman
um who's been through a trauma when
experience right
and then uh a male figure shows up
and whether you know my hair complexion
whatever it could have
it could have been a trigger for her you
know me interviewing her talking to her
so they want to avoid that giving these
women triggers
you know what i mean uh like uh
there was one woman i interviewed who
said that she's a survivor and a leader
and she you know
had been through a lot but she said that
if her pimp came in the room right now
and said let's go and she'd been out of
life like say 10 years but she said if
her pimp came in the room right now said
let's go
she said she would get up and walk out
with him yeah
so this living trauma that these go
through that these women go through was
real
and so i had to you know the level of
sensitivity around that
and having to having to live and breathe
the story for a long time before i was
able to put it on paper
and you wrote the film no i actually i
came up with the story
and i kind of yeah i kind of did the
outline and the treatment but then
steve peterson came on and he wrote the
script how did you meet steve
i met steve because i was working on um
the first film
um it was called diamonds in the rough
this was the one going back to africa
and uh steve had did give he did some
work on that script and i met him
through another producer tom shell
and then when we took the script uh
skinning the game to howard who
eventually produced it howard bear show
we can't do films
we went through a whole nother
development process yeah because i had
originally wrote the script like
um i don't know if you remember the
movie traffic with michael douglas
but it was it was yeah it was what
happened when that movie had multiple
story lines
like it was him it was this was this and
so that's how i envisioned telling
the story of these girls like i had one
being abducted i had one
was had a romeo pimp who had groomed her
into the life i had
another woman that was uh a seasoned
prostitute in there so it was like these
multiple story lines
intersecting right but then when i took
it to howard bearish and howard was very
seasoned at making movies especially
independent movies and how would it work
with ava duvenay and he worked with her
on
um middle of nowhere and her first film
i will follow
and he had you know he had films go to
sundance so he was like the seasoned
shepherd producer
and so when i took him the story he was
like i like it and he wanted to get
involved
because he he himself had been touched
by trafficking also
and so and he was also coming into this
new awareness of what this was
because it was everywhere and it was all
around us and i started to share the
story with him and
uh the more i shared the more he got
enthused and wanted to get behind the
film
uh but he thought it was just too large
like it was too much going on it was too
many different stories
so his first suggestion was you got to
streamline you got to streamline it and
you know tell a singular story right and
this was for not just it was for
budgetary reasons
it was for festival reasons you know uh
yeah and it was for good filmmaking
reasons at that at that particular point
too so it's just that it's not all over
the place and we didn't have the budget
to really support that
and so i went back to the woodshed and
then that's when i um
i leaned heavily on uh jayla
and jayla i met jayla she's a
trafficking or survivor and a leader and
she's
she this woman is she's amazing an
amazing woman and she's rescued over
5000 girls
five thousand five hundred boys and
girls within an eighteen year period
and i found her i don't know by chance
fate i don't know you call it but
she was in watts teaching in her
grandmother's bait or
one of her relatives basement church
about how gangs are trafficking young
girls
and i saw the flyer how gangs are
trafficking young girls
learn about this and find out how to
prevent it so i went
and uh wow she blew my way she blew me
away
and then i met with her afterward and we
talked and uh and then she became very
integral
and it's sort of the development of the
way the story was being unfolded now
and she came on board as a consultant
and uh um
yeah as a consultant for us because
donald the story is about a mother and a
daughter and then
yeah getting a formula yeah she and she
was always in it the mother and daughter
was always in it
but um i it wasn't about
a woman former prostitute rescuing her
and that's what howard made the input
and said you got to streamline it
and then we realized that um to tell
that particular story i needed to know
more about that woman
because i didn't know much about her you
know the prostitute now rescuing girls
and that's when i i started to research
and talk to jayla a lot and delete a
miller
was there ever a time you wanted to give
up filmmaking wow
you know what i have to be in terms of
me wanting to give up filmmaking
i don't think there's ever been a time i
wanted to give up honestly i mean
there's always been
there's been hard times i mean there's
been times where i've
uh there was one time when i first moved
to la
and i literally lived in six different
places in seven
no i lived in eight different places in
six months
and there was one time when my friend
moved i moved with him
because i was just couch surfing i would
be here and i'd be here
so and then there was a time i lived out
of my car
right literally i was just living out of
my car and so
i've had some really hard times but i've
never wanted to give up
never in terms of and maybe it's because
i just went too far down that road
and i was like oh there's nothing else i
want to do but
um the vision of being a director and a
filmmaker has always been there
you know despite you know circumstances
yeah but
but i've had you know looked out of my
car i lived out of a sound stage
um yeah
i've i've yeah paid the price
and not that everybody has to do that
right
um but when you're you know when you
have a dream
and you're committed you know and that's
and it's something that you believe in
wholeheartedly then you'll do whatever
it takes
you'll do whatever it takes to make it
happen
so you were living out of your car and
were you still
being creative or at least attempting to
be creative no it was hard
to answer your question living out of my
car and being creative it was hard
and uh no i wasn't i was still writing
but it was hard and at some point um
i had to just find a job and that's when
i started to do the sound thing more
seriously
you know just to keep a roof over my
head you know people don't realize how
hard it is to be a filmmaker in la but
when you first get here
you don't know anybody it's tough and so
i had to get out of survival mode
right i had to get to a place where now
i have money coming in
i'm paying the rent i'm eating i don't
have to call home and
ask my mother for money for you know for
rent i had to
so so being in survival mode is a really
hard place to be
and uh but la is not it's not an easy
place
to break in it's just not you know you
come out here
a lot of people doing what you want to
do um more some more committed than
others
uh relationships take precedent a lot of
time but when you first get there who do
you know
right you're building your foundation
you're building your network
and so and that takes time it takes a
lot of time
my advice is sometimes when people first
get out here i'm like
you know sometimes before you even get
here if you're wherever you are
you know idaho or you know or oakland
california if you will
but you know to get a body of work write
scripts have four or five scripts
you know or two three or three scripts
don't just come out here one script have
two or three scripts
then come out here right then that way
you you're gonna be struggling you're
gonna be living but you've got a body of
work now you can kind of go out and shop
that
uh but but to do that while you're out
here it can be really tough
especially when you're struggling so
once you
got this stable job and you got an
apartment or
your roommate or whatever yeah then did
you did it happen
gradually or did you feel like okay now
now that i have something coming in
every two weeks
or whatever this paycheck i can start
writing and whatever yeah yeah well i
gotta tell you i had i had to get out of
the
out of the place of i would meet people
and they would give me hope like i would
get my script to somebody and someone
like oh
i can do what i can do but then i had to
realize that a lot of people in l.a just
talk
right and so um and i would call home
mom i meant such and such or
or uh you know girlfriend if i had it at
the time oh
i guess got the script so i just had to
get out of that place right
and so now having done it for a lot of
years
now um i have ex i don't i take the
expectation off of it
like i have hopes that um everything is
going to happen
but i take the expectation like meaning
i'm going to give this person a script
they're going to green light it we're
going to make it and it's going to be
done
because that doesn't happen a lot of
times
right and if you always set yourself up
for that
like oh it's going to happen then you're
living in a constant state of
disappointment
so i think the best thing to do is just
sort of give it to somebody and release
give it to somebody you have high hopes
but don't be too attached
to it or the expectation right because
you may set yourself
up for disappointment and um and a lot
of people i know
a lot of writers i know go through a lot
of depression you know i don't want to
come out of the house i want to talk to
people
and so i'm not i'm not that kind of
person um
but yeah i've just learned to sort of
just release
i mean put the effort you know in the
case of howard
when i gave him the script and we
started to talk about it i mean it was a
year later
i mean we developed that thing for a
whole year like so it didn't just happen
like i gave
it to him piqued his interest he liked
it but he wanted to develop it
right and he developed it me not even
knowing he was gonna make it
i mean it was never a promise or him
saying oh yeah you know if we get to
this place i'm gonna give you the money
or i'm gonna finance it it was just
it was a cordial it was a great
relationship the script was becoming
better so i didn't mind the relationship
because he would give us notes and the
script would be better
so at the end of that process whether he
was going to make it or not i was going
to have a better script
so i was like there's a win-win for me
and then uh but then at the end of that
year
he felt really good about the script and
where it was at in terms of
place and he said let's go ahead and
make it i think we can make it in
uh you know i think it was at that time
it was maybe in august and he said we
can make it in november
and he had another film he was going to
do before mine
and then he pulled the trigger on it
yeah i always think it's like a kiss of
death when somebody says especially to a
young person
i want to help you yeah and i don't mean
to sound negative but
you really do have to have your guard up
especially those those words yeah yeah
listen i've met with uh since i've
directed that film skin in the game i've
met with some big tv directors
right i won't even name the names and uh
but i don't go in there thinking oh
they're gonna help me they're gonna put
me on
you know that's that's what some people
young people like that term being put on
somebody's gonna grab you you're gonna
have some kind of wizard of oz or boom
and now you're on
and i just it doesn't happen like that a
lot of times
and then you have to ask what's it in
for that other person sure you know like
i
generously give myself to other people
now i want i want to help other people
you know but i know it's because it's
just part of who i am but some people
aren't built like that
some people you know i mean they may
give you one word of advice and that's
it don't ask me for nothing else
right and so and some people will go
beyond that but
so i i've just learned to kind of um
just take what people can give me you
know take
and to the point about meeting with
these directors i don't expect anything
from them hey listen if the guys can
tell me
what helped them what worked for them
sometimes that's good enough for me
yeah yeah i know there was another
person that was upset because they felt
that the peers around them
had or the people around them that were
sort of peers had made it and that
person hadn't yeah and they're upset
they said they won't help me yeah but at
some point i
i have to think that someone can't risk
their reputation
and just trying to pull up their friends
too well i've had that happen too and my
conversation around that especially when
it comes down to
uh well in general it's a tough thing to
do because
um well
let me back up i'm gonna say what i
wanted to say so
uh when it comes down to black
filmmakers and women women filmmakers i
admire what abe was doing
you know like he was hiring women
filmmakers to direct for the first time
on her show queen sugar right and
by giving them a shot and some of these
women have done shorts but most of them
have done independent features but
nobody looks at them right
so then when they take meetings they're
saying at the meetings
tv meetings that is i want to direct tv
they're like well have you ever done tv
what becomes a catch-22
well how am i going to do tv if i've
never done it and how are you going to
give me a shot
if i've never done it but yet they've
done these feature films right
but ava is eliminating all that she's
giving women a shot
to direct qualified women now women that
have proven themselves you know
and but we can more of us can benefit
from that right
like especially for me
when you're talking about like i don't
use minorities but when you're talking
about like
people that don't traditionally have a
shot and that have been kept
out of the mainstream right so then i
think you have to set up not just lip
service programs
but work with these people and if they
qualify to get them in
sort of creating this new pool of
filmmakers
if you will is that a lot of the
filmmakers she's reaching out to
have independent films they've done
shorts so they've done something so
they've qualified themselves on a
certain level right
and now she's giving him access to
directv
and now so when they go back to
producers in television and say
um and a lot of the directors by the way
have gone on sally richardson
you know cheryl daniel have gone on to
do television
beyond ava but she's given them that
start but these filmmakers
have all paid dues and i make i make
that a
specific point because people don't want
to pay dues anymore they just want to be
put on
they want to come out to la and they
want somebody to just
like a fairy godmother to just come in
and say here
or they want to write one script or they
want to write two scripts and say oh i'm
ready
you know and it just takes more than
that um
i've paid a lot of dues uh and i think
that
people should pay dues you know and when
i say pay dues it's really about just
uh getting better at your craft right or
doing
you know sometimes you have to be an
assistant before you can be a writer
before you can be in the writer's room
right or sometimes you have to be uh you
know direct shorts before you can direct
the feature
right so it's about paying those kind of
dues um in my case
i don't even know if i look at it as
dues anymore it's it's more as just a
necessary
stepping stone to get where you want to
be like
i've paid dues but for me now it's like
climbing the mountain
now i'm here okay and now i got to get
to here and i'm grabbing here and so for
me just because i've
done an independent film i still feel
like i'm paying dues
like i've gone listen i've come a long
way and i want to
applaud my efforts and the people around
me that have supported me
to do this feature film right but to do
another film
at another budget point is going to
require another kind of paying dues
so i haven't made it by any stretch of
the imagination right and what is making
it mean anyway
you know so i mean i mean i think we all
set our own standard for what
success is and so i'd like to think that
i'm successful at this level in terms of
having done this feature film but
there's other milestones
and other goals that i want to set for
myself
can we go back to just what steps you
took either to meet
howard barrish the producer or how did
you
what was your like initial pitch to him
yeah howard
bearish was an interesting um
milestone for me because prior to
meeting howard
i had developed scripts and written
scripts
but i was always in the minds remember
i'm learning about filmmaking
but in i'm in the mindset i'm gonna get
into an independent
i'm trying to raise independent
financing right and for me that looks
like my mother may be giving ten
thousand dollars if my mother had it
or a friend giving five thousand dollars
just finding
money like that or and i was led down
the wrong path
so many times talking to people in
atlanta talking to a casting director
who knew somebody with money in atlanta
and they get excited about the project
and say oh they yeah they we want to get
we want to get this thing going we like
it blah blah blah you don't hear from
them again
right and that had happened so many
times like i mean
the meeting the amount of people i had
talked to that weren't really
i'm gonna say i'm gonna use a qualifier
here they never produced a film before
they never
uh given money to a film before so that
becomes
for any filmmaker going out there to
making a movie i mean certainly you can
work with people that have never done it
before and they're going to give money
but i think i just get it's just a
better
fit if somebody's done it before like
you take your film
or script to a production company that
makes it you know or you take it to
another
company that makes movies like you know
they have a history of that right
versus um okay let me you know
take it to this person let's take it to
this person i had done that for years i
don't know why but i was doing that for
years
and so and i was always reaching dead
ends okay and this is before um
gofundme and um and and all that
but uh so i had uh i had worked on the
script
and i met with a camera guy friend of
mine
and he had worked with howard he worked
with him
on a few projects so he knew howard
right and the camera guy said uh
he said yeah you know i think i can get
it to this guy uh howard bearish you
know he makes movies and uh
yeah because he he you know he did some
stuff with ava uh
duva doof i mean i didn't even know who
avery duvenne was right he's like
uh it's a friend of mine right he's like
uh he did some stuff with ava
ava duva i said duvenay he said yeah
yeah that's her that's her that's her
i said really so i got excited
immediately because i was like oh howard
barry she said stuff for david doing
and i had already started up on ava
right i knew who ava was
and eve at that time i think she did did
she sell what was she doing selma
yeah she was shooting selma and uh you
see the
in the middle of shooting some more
shot selma and so i was like yeah yeah
if you can make the introduction please
and so he made the introduction
and howard called me and uh we had
well no i sent howard the script first
and then it took howard a while to read
it but you learn that in this business
too people are like
like people are not pressed to read your
script you're not gonna give it to them
they're like oh yeah i want to read over
the weekend
it just doesn't happen and so you learn
to i mean i'm even more detached now but
back then i was still like
has he read it yet has he read it yet
but i know i'm patiently like okay don't
call him in a week don't call him in two
weeks
but then i think i called him like maybe
three weeks later and he said oh no i
haven't read it yet but i'm gonna get to
it i'm gonna get to it
and then uh the next call he called me
and he said i read your script and i
didn't know howard from adam
right that was a really nice guy like
he's really cool he's really like
unassuming you wouldn't know that he has
a bathtub award
or that he's been nominated for an emmy
you know that he uh
produces these big cw campaign
commercials i mean you just wouldn't
know it
and so that's what i liked about him
like he's really like just
low-key and assuming unassuming and so
he just had an off-the-cuff chat yeah i
liked your script he said you know
it's okay he says you know why don't you
come in we can talk
and uh he invited me down to the office
and i came down to the office and i met
with him
and we just i think we kind of just hit
it off right away
again he's just a very unassuming
low-key kind of guy
and uh you know he talked about ava you
know
the journey of making independent films
and why he was passionate about
supporting younger artists new emerging
filmmakers anyhow he had uh
he was just committed to that i mean
he's just you know he was committed
today he did it with ava and
so he uh took the film
you know took the script and then we
started to work together at that point
in terms of developing and like i said
it took over a year
to get it to where we needed it to be
and during that point i would just
rewrite it i would give it to him and he
would give me notes and
rewrite it and give it to him give me
notes and so we went back and forth
for you know a few drafts until we got
it to where we
needed it to be and you emailed him
initially
do you is that right yeah i emailed him
uh
or did i call him i think i called him i
think i called i don't know
you know sometimes i write the emails
but it's like it depends
because i don't want to catch people off
guard you know when you write when you
call them right away it's like oh
hello you know they have to adjust
themselves and i don't want them to
play pretend and all that stuff so um
but i think in howard's case because
brian the guy
i met set up the introduction
um i think i called him
i think i called him i may have emailed
him i don't know
i don't know it could have been an email
actually and he gave me his number and
he said let's talk
it may have been an email sure it could
have been because i like that soft intro
sometimes it gives people
they can gather themselves on the other
end you know well he doesn't know if
you're a solar panel salesman
yeah he didn't know you know of course
and you know how it took a big gamble
too because to see
in my mind i'm thinking i'm ready i can
do a film i know i can right
but from the other person who's
financing the film
who's going to produce it he didn't know
because
it's not like i done i did yeah i did
some shorts and he saw the shorts but
it's not like i had done a feature
before
features a whole nother animal we can
talk about that it's like um
a short film is a short film to itself
but a feature
in terms of shooting it we did ours in
17 days
the actors following first act drama
second act third act and then arc of
characters
and then um uh just the stamina
as a director to show up every day with
with a game plan it takes something you
know and everybody
everybody and sometimes you can fail on
the job like you know what i mean like
you could be a first-time director and
get all set
but you better have first a.d who's very
clear about
laying out a schedule uh a dp who's done
this numerous times so they've got you
sort of
um they're supporting you in making that
first feature and so that the margin of
error for you becomes
less right does that make sense because
you're a first-time director but yet
you've got
you know an a.d an experienced producer
in howard
and you got a dp who can sort of steer
the ship but when you
when you don't have that you know and
then you got a first-time director out
there
anything can happen so you you don't
know
you know you become an unproven talent
until you've done it
you know and uh so i knew i could do it
i felt i was very confident about that
i've been on enough sets
and my experience doing the shorts and
the documentary and i had
i had an acumen around film i studied a
lot of films i had uh
yeah but i mean the things surprised me
on the set too i mean it was like
yeah it was it was still it was still a
challenging experience you know like i
was still figuring things out
you you know what i mean like i remember
one day i showed up on set and kiera
kelly was our dp
kara kelly now shoots uh queen sugar uh
uh black woman dp uh really talented
and so i remember one morning we did a
shot list top to bottom right
and so we knew exactly how we were going
to approach each scene
the movie in itself you can kind of do
that with a 16-day shoot and you or you
better do that
you better be very specific about what
you're going to cover because you don't
have a lot of
like we're not we don't have a spielberg
set where we can play with
or we're going to shoot this one scene
one day you know or david fincher yeah
let's just do this one scene
one day you know like we got to shoot
like really four or five scenes in a day
and so um but i showed it one morning
and i said i got an idea for the shot
right and she looked at me she said yeah
i said yeah why don't we start here
and put it on a dolly and then move it
up here as they get out of the car right
he said wow that's really cool i like
that she said but that's not on the shot
list we didn't talk about that
i said i know i know but it's cool
because i got inspired right i got
inspired that night before i said i know
it's a cool shot it's gonna look really
cool
and uh she said yeah no but we didn't
talk about it and i said
but she said but you want to do it i see
yeah she said but it's gonna take a
little time because we gotta put the
dolly blah blah blah blah
i said nah but let's go let's go for it
and they started to set up the track
right
and one dolly man and
what and he was one dollar grip and he
was laying the track
and he was you know leveling the track
and then hadn't even put the dolly up
there yet and i looked at him i said
damn this is 10 minutes
and he hadn't even laid that track yet
and he's still trying to level it
and i'm like 15 minutes and i said scrap
it
let's go back to the plan let's go back
she said you sure she's a really
professional dp and what i liked about
it was she's going to give me my vision
right so she was cooperative in that
sense you know a lot of dp's
you know argumentative and whatnot i
mean not all of them but you know i've
heard stories
but she was very like it's your vision
let's do it um
but i saw how long it was taking to put
that track
up and i said kill it kill it let's go
back and she said you sure i said yeah
so that was an instance where in terms
of me growing as a director knowing
especially with this budget
what you can do and what you can't do
right and we could not afford
whether time money or otherwise to lay a
track down and do a dolly
and i didn't have a trained crew like
that you know like i didn't have
i've been on other sets where uh they
have
dolly grips and two or three people
working to dial it we didn't have that
you know we had like two people in the
dollar in the grip department two people
in the lighting department
some days we spread out to three but on
bigger scenes
but we didn't have that so i was like
you know what so i learned
my lesson i may have cost this 15
minutes but if i had continued on that
path to do that shot
i would probably cost us about 45
minutes really
because then now you have to allow for
the shot
one time you have to allow for the dolly
oh they missed the dolly mark
then you got to allow for the pull focus
oops he missed his mark so everybody got
allowed for a mistake right
and then the guy pushing it oh he made a
mistake so it's like
you know it it increases the um
uh the take value or the ratios in terms
of shooting it too
so i surrendered it but i say that by
way of a learning lesson
you know i learned by doing the first
feature too
and imagine if she had fought you on it
you might have spent a half hour
trying to prove your point oh yeah so it
was brilliant that she said okay
oh yeah you sure okay let's and then you
got to see within 15 minutes
that it was gonna cost more time yeah
exactly
exactly so you know sometimes it's just
there's no getting around doing a first
feature
like you have to do it and like people
think it's
i don't know if people think they can
dial it in or it's easy
i don't i sometimes i get that
impression when i talk to filmmakers
especially that
somebody that haven't done it before
they think they can just they're going
to be great at it but
you know it's like anything else you
know whether you do sound
or you deep they don't look at it like a
dp like a dp you know
when you shoot something it's going to
take a minute to perfect your craft
it's just going to take a minute
lighting you know
camera lenses it's a very technical
thing but
being a good director can be that too
right sometimes people think you just
step on set and just oh boom let's make
it happen
but no you know the good directors the
really good ones they've worked at it
they worked at it
so um i have an appreciation for
directing and
i do a lot of studying on it blocking
you know
coverage you know working with actors
i've taken classes
you know in terms of directing classes
brad barnes does a great
uh director's working with actors class
i've taken that frederick huggles
writing because i think all directors
should be able to write i mean
it helps it helps you to understand
story arc
where it's going you don't become it's
just you know
yeah it just helps you become a better
story technician
so you know i i believe in the craft i
believe in knowing the craft i've worked
with actors a lot
and so it becomes very helpful yeah
having done many short films when you
actually started with the feature
did you think you were going to be as
calm
under pressure when things you're having
to come up with not just a plan b but a
plan c
and then you know that there's all this
money riding on and there's all this
time
you got to make your day yeah did you
realize how much pressure there would be
having to make these decisions on the
fly yeah it was gradual it was gradual
because
um i heard somebody explain it to me
like this
like you could be a producer right and
say somebody's driving you there's a
driver and he drives you to
no no this is a better example okay so
you're going to school
right and so your mother's driving you
every day
she's driving every day to school you're
just kind of sitting there you're on
your phone you're talking or you're on
the email
and you've done this route to school
like a million times right
and then one morning your mother says
okay you drive and all of a sudden
you're like uh
which way am i going right so it can be
like that a little bit
you know like i had i've been even
though i'd been on a million sets
and i had worked as a sound technician
and um
you know i've added it's not you know
but to be in the seat of dr
directing it's a whole different
conversation the decisions that are
being put on you the questions i mean
you get a million questions a day right
and then
having to just be very clear about your
shot and then being able to walk away
from a scene saying we got it or we
don't got it
we need to stay longer right or how
okay i shot this i took more time than i
needed to i really going to screw myself
up at the end of the day
so now i have to think about a wonder
and wow i can get make my day that way
so i mean it was it was it was very
it was challenging i mean it was it was
challenging at times you know i was
getting that muscle up
you know to become yeah i was getting
that muscle i think i think
i came with a lot of strong stuff like i
work with actors a lot
and so that was sort of easy for me you
know
um technically working with the
equipment
was it was i had a handle on that
i think it was the scheduling and kind
of knowing how long things would take
like the action sequences i did like i
did not know it was going to take as
long as it took
and so when we did the schedule and so
i'm sitting there as the ads doing the
schedule
and he's saying yeah this is this is and
i'm signing off on it
you know and i'm signing off on the
basic basic i don't really have the exp
i mean i'm not
i haven't done the action right but i'm
signing off on it basically yeah it
should take that long to take that long
but it's the difference between that and
having experience doing it
right that's why you're going to do your
second feature your third feature you're
like no no no i need more time
no no that's not going to work oh yeah i
can cut that yeah we can get that in the
early point and
we're done you know like we did a lot of
car shots the hostess trey i mean one
day the guy set up the hostess straight
and it wasn't my fault and it wasn't um
the ads fault but the guy just took
forever to
set up the hostess tray for the car
mount shot right
it's because he didn't know what he was
doing he just did not know what he was
doing and it took him a long time
or i shouldn't say he was green he
wasn't an experienced guy so that's the
other thing when you work with
independent or lower budgeted films
sometimes you're not getting the cream
of the crop
right so you're getting guys that you
know trying to break in trying to you
know
you know for elevate themselves in their
own careers but this is where they are
right now
so the guy just took forever and so i
was like wow this is killing us man this
is killing us
and so i had a minute i had to just
switch up and say we can't do this we
got to go to another shot
or he screwed because he didn't know
what he was doing or he just screwed us
now we had to go from
i couldn't do the cross coverage i
wanted now i had to do one coverage
right
from one side of the car and so now and
i learned this when we were doing this
the actors the actors already known this
because they had played
um they had been on a lot of sets you
know you got to give credit to actors
man i mean
the really good ones they do this a lot
and they know what to do
so when they played the scene they
played to this camera so even though i'm
side angle
they played this way right and so
i covered the camera covered their
performance in a way where they knew the
blocking
right in the car now the minute i said
to them i think we have time to go to
the other side they were like whoa
oh we played for this camera you switch
if now if we'd known you were going that
way
look we could have played it like this
she could have turned
but we thought it was going to be one
angle you see i was like ah
got it got it so we just stuck with the
one shot
yeah i learned that you know what i mean
on the set that day
okay so actors you know they know you
know but i always like to inform my
actors anyway this is the blocking this
is the shot
blah blah blah but the minute i said
we're going to switch and go another way
they were like
but we played it this way for this
camera it looks beautiful for that
camera
but if they had known we were going two
cameras guess what they'd be turning
like this
turning like that yeah so
yeah there's no there's no um there's no
getting around doing a first-time
feature
and i don't think and hey listen you can
do a lot of preparation
but until you're on that set until
you're there the first day
um i mean it still becomes a first time
feature experience
yeah just be as prepared as you can be
and surround yourself with good
people and we did that you know and
howard having done
uh this a number of times i mean
sometimes i get to sit in the morning
i'm seeing howard moving to jenny
i mean he's a hands-on producer too so
not as that and he used to be an a.d
so he was an a.d in canada for a lot of
years before he became a producer
so uh the last two days we lost our a.d
because he was sick
i mean he just got i think he had some
kind of food poisoning or whatever not
from the set but
you know he got sick and so howard had
stepped in
and guess what both days we
we managed to wrap before schedule like
an hour early
both days and he was so efficient and on
time
and it was just like i was like howard
how did that he say hey man
but he knows how to a.d you know he
knows how to run a set
so i was blessed to have him as a
producer on my first
film can we talk about the time frame
and the conversation that you had with
howard about
developing or redeveloping the script
for skin in the game because he saw it
he said i like it but yeah
yeah so howard had liked it and he had
uh
uh there was no commitment there was no
commitment that he was gonna make it
there was no i mean we were just doing
the dance if you will
you know and at the time because it was
benefiting the script and because it was
becoming better
i was like okay this this works you know
what i mean but i didn't know if he was
going to make it or not
i didn't know at the end of this journey
so i was still sort of
you know still trying to find a way to
do it independently
like if you will like i was still trying
to raise a hundred thousand dollars here
i thought maybe we could have done it
for three hundred
two hundred thousand dollars so i was
like okay well maybe at one point i
think we can do a fifty thousand dollars
so i was like because i was just you
know
i was yeah i don't know if i was i'm not
gonna use one always word desperate
but i wanted to make a movie like i
wanted to make a movie right
but you got to be careful with that word
desperation because that desperate
causes you to rush a script into
production
being desperate causes you to uh oversee
like over overlook certain things like
the script may not mechanically work or
maybe have problems but she's like oh
god i just got to make this movie
so desperate is not a place you want to
be
you know you talked about being on set
sometimes and you just don't want to be
that guy who's
or girl woman who's on set being
desperate you want to be calm about the
whole thing right and so i had peace of
mind during the whole process
but i didn't know if he was going to
make it or not and so i was looking for
other
at that time probably you know seeing
how we could do it for a hundred
thousand dollars or whatnot
um and it was it was a year i mean you
look up but you know a year goes by kind
of fast
like you're like uh wait a minute three
months have passed you know you do a
rewrite
two months to pass you give him a script
it takes him a month to read it you know
then he gives you back he calls you
there's notes then he travels he's
hey boom he's he's at a sundance film
festival
you know so then that month is down and
then he comes back and then he has to
gear up for this
commercial thing so it's like i'm
working so it doesn't feel like a year
but a year goes by right before before
we make the movie
yeah and the script is constantly
getting better and it's constantly
evolving and
we're constantly in communication and
talking you know
about you know you know what it could
look like and
yeah so then sending him revisions
and then he gives you notes yeah i was
sending revisions he had had uh
uh mike now is uh is over there he's a
co-producer over there and
mike would give us notes i would go
sometimes i'd walk in we'd sit down we'd
talk
they'd both give me notes we could
change this whatever we think about this
and it was never like
dictatorial you know they would just be
making like like suggestions
you know i think it would be better if
we did this and blah blah blah because
howard in his company they really
i think they protect or they they
respect
the vision of the filmmaker right so it
wasn't like they were trying to change
my vision at all it was just
always about like how do we make this a
better house this can be a better house
this can be a better what if we add this
what if we take this away
you know like uh the ending was a big
was a big thing for us
you know because sundance and usually
independent film
usually like places like sunday like
darker endings
right they like gritty endings and so
you know we played with the ending a lot
you know but then i think
there was uh who told me this yeah one
of my survivor
women told me don't make it uh
a dark ending she told me even though
the reality for most of these girls is
they don't get out right a lot of them
truthfully either succumb to drugs you
know
uh they get worn out and they uh
some of them die you know i mean you
know the lifespan of a prostitute is
only like
seven years yeah and so you know or the
od so it becomes it's like a very
grim experience and so but she told me
do not
show the ending so in our movie i don't
want to give you any spoilers
but there was a point where the hair uh
the lead girl gets caught into the life
and doesn't come back
but this person the survivor told me she
said don't do that because she says
the pimps will use it as a recruiting
tool
and they'll use it to say look see she
couldn't get out
you see see this movie this is the truth
this is your reality so don't even try
and everybody it really it meant
something to me so i shared that with
howard and then too you know and uh i
think it
impacted all of us you know in terms of
the way we shaped
the the movie toward the end
yeah did anybody try to talk you out of
making the movie in that they thought
maybe you can't get distribution
because of the subject matter
distributors might be scared of it
yeah well that's that that's where
howard was key but
i remember one of our first meetings and
he repeated this a lot
he said listen this can movie after we
finish it it can be a paperweight
it can uh it can be an exercise of
futility
it can sit up there on the bookshelf
there it's just uh you know
um you know just it's like just
collecting dust
right it may go nowhere right he was
very real i mean like i was like
i mean you know i mean i was like you
know like
because that's that was my thinking
right at all but he had
again he's an experienced producer and
he's done this a number of times and
then
we met again we were getting ready to
make the movie he said
listen this can either sit on the shelf
it can be a paperweight
or it can be an exercise of utility like
he said that exact same thing
and um do you still want to do this you
know
and i said yeah you know and but see he
had been to the other side of the
mountain
he had been the journey before so he
knew right so even now
as we get skin in the game out there to
audiences
and it's been a great journey it's been
a great journey right um
but we didn't get into sundance we
didn't get into
tribeca you know we didn't get into
toronto uh
we didn't get into south by southwest we
didn't get into any of the top tier
festivals
right so that was a whole year because
if you know anything about festivals
they want to premiere your film
first the top tier ones if they don't
get access to your film first
like say if you premiered it chicago
international film festival and then
sunday and say okay we want your movie
we want the exclusive rights to the
premier and you're like well we already
premiered it son
at chicago they're like well we don't
want it
so that happens a lot so you have to um
gauge it and we had to go a whole like
almost cycle year
of trying to get into the big festivals
then when we didn't get into the big
festivals then we could back up and say
okay we didn't get into
all the big ones right and why do you
want the big ones because the
distributors are there
because the buyers are there because the
national press is there
right the attention is there so you want
to hold out for those festivals
but when you don't get it then you say
okay now what are the second tier
festivals
and uh so then we were fortunate i mean
we were fortunate in the sense that we
premiered at urban world in new york
in september which is a great festival
you know we had a great
premiere there then we went up to uh
whistler film festival in canada
and then we ended with the pan african
film festival and we won best director
best first feature film right so yeah it
was uh it's been a journey
but to your point about how we're
talking about the paperweight but now
we're in the process of distributing it
right and distributing it is almost as
hard as making it
like when you ask yourself what is the
hardest part writing the script
making it or distributing it i'm almost
like
well distributing it is hard as hell
because now you got to get it out there
to people people have to see it
you want people to see it and so um
yeah it takes it's and we're an indie
film so it's like ch
choo choo choo choo choo yes you can yes
you can choo choo choo choo choo
you know so plus it's not as sexy
to be distributing it yeah when you're
on set oh yeah
you're you're even though there's a
stressful moment and then you made
another point about the
subject matter so so howard was also
very clear
this is this is not a popular subject
matter
or a lot of people don't want to see
that kind of thing it's in the shadows
right
and so even my wife for instance never
read the script
even when we finished the film she never
saw it and she was actually when i was
writing the scriptures like how can you
write that how can you you know i mean
it created something for her in terms of
just the subject matter and we had two
little girls
so it was and i understand it right and
so i knew
just translated from that to what howard
was saying it's not gonna be an
easy sell and you know
for whatever reason people are not gonna
just be
it didn't matter how good the film is
you're just going to be drawn to the
subject but i would say i'm willing to
roll the dice
in spite of all that he said let's roll
the dice
knowing what he knew is a businessman he
said let's roll the dice yeah
it seems like you're attracted or you're
willing to
explore dark subject matter and and know
that a lot of people may not
want to see they may know about young
children working in mines
and it's horrible but i do i really want
to spend years
why do you think you're willing to go
there well because
as much as you talk about the dark
subject matter and the darkness
of the uh why do i go there i'm an
optimist
and so i like to see the light in the
darkness you know
sometimes i think the light is in the
darkness right
and so i'm gonna go there because i'm
still fighting for the hope and the
possibility
right so i'm never going to tell a story
where it's just dark
right and then at the ending it's it's
like unconscionable and
you know i'm always gonna there's gonna
be a spin on it
right or there's gonna be a um a take on
it so in the diamond mine
thing you know we got the kids out of
the mines you know we funded them in
soccer
and we put them in schools so that was
like there was
there was something that came out of
that right and so
with the girls it was important for me
to tell the subject matter
but it was also important to tell that
one story of possibility and hope
you know the girl that made it the girl
that did get out
and so we can cling on to that you know
so i'm not afraid of the darkness
but you know for me it there has to be
that um
that thing where i'm not gonna just live
in there just you know
wallow in it yeah there's got to be some
um
some hope some possibility so i'm always
fighting for the possibility and the
hope
has anyone just said make a romantic
comedy why
don't you know it's just it's an easier
sell or what yeah
and and if if your heart's not in it
how do you feel about that yeah yeah no
i've i've gotten that
um you know just do a romantic comedy
just do a light
uh drama um which i probably will do
one day but um that's not who i am
you know it's just not not who i am in
terms of that
uh yeah in terms of developing material
in terms of my interest right now
in terms of what i'm excited about
but i hope to you know i hope to lighten
it up do a romantic comedy one day do do
comedy
but just right now it's this is just you
know this is where my interest is this
is what
what draws me so is your sort of
approach to filmmaking similar to life
where you just kind of tell it like it
is
and has that worked for you or has it
ever rubbed people the wrong way
it's interesting that you should mention
that i'm so glad you mentioned that
actually
uh because there's two school of
thoughts and i've heard uh gina prince
life with the director of love and
basketball and
uh disappearing acts she talks about
this
as a writer and director she said um
you can tell it like it is right like
you can exactly replicate life
and this this is what it is and if it's
bad it's bad if it's if it's
uh you know dark it's dark and just
i'm just gonna show you like it is and
she says but she prefers to tell a story
that is how it could be opposed to just
what it is
and i subscribe to that you know i don't
mind showing it like it is but i also
want it
to be like this is how it could be
mm-hmm
and you think that's from your parents
because they were willing to
to help some of the other kids and and
you know they were always sort of this
foundation for you yeah i think
i think a lot of it goes back to my
parents because um
i lived i mean i lived in a realm of
possibility
you can do this my mother always said
you can do this and she always supported
me and whatever i did i wanted to be a
filmmaker she's like
you can be a filmmaker if i wanted to be
go to nyu she said you can go to nyu
so she's always been in my corner even
when sometimes she's like
uh well i wasn't a sound man you need
did you join the union you know you need
to be in the union you know
you need the foundation you secured i
was like oh mom you know i need to
i need to stay loose i need to be you
know i can't be like
in the union because that means i'm a
sound man i can't be too much like
i can't be considered that and even
though i'm in the union now right
but uh or i became in the union at one
point but i was like nah i need to stay
loose
and so um but they've been they've
always created
a level they've always supported me in a
way where i could create possibility
and so i think yeah it filters down into
my work
where i don't just want to show what is
but i also want to show what's possible
was the first day on set for skin in the
game more emotional than any of the
short
films that you had reported to or done
on your own
yeah i think uh you talk about the first
date but i i got to tell you
there was probably two periods where i
cried i just couldn't believe this was
happening
i mean like that kind of cry like i was
i was very grateful
of having had the experience i had a
moment you know usually when you're
shooting a film there's no moments to
do anything but like let's keep marching
ahead let's keep marching it and once
you get that ball rolling it's like
you're rolling next day second day third
you know so it's like but there was
there were two days where i probably
paused and i just some tears came in my
eyes because i was just so
overwhelmed with the fact that this was
happening
and i was grateful and it was it was
sort of
victorious for me in a way that all this
15-year journey
was culminating into this you know and
then what happens to is you've been told
no
so many times that you know
you get beat down by the no and so that
when the yes happens sometimes there's a
disbelief like
is this really happening is this really
happening
and so it took a moment to sink in
that this is really happening and i'm
really directing my first feature
so yeah
wow yeah did did it get in your head at
all like mess with you a little bit or
then once the train was going you were
just well you know the thing is that's
the thing about it once the train is
moving it's moving and you're the leader
and um the day the day or the actors or
the shots that you choose
it it rises or falls with you so you
just have to embrace that and i i braced
that pretty fast
like i just i didn't have too much time
to sit back and be like oh uh
you know i had to get into into director
mode
you know and that meant efficiency that
meant you know having the actors
believe in me and have confidence in me
as the directors and that meant coming
prepared
and you know i like to work with my
actors you know so i like to you know
sit time to rehearse even though we had
limited rehearsal up time
up up front of the film like maybe one
or two days which wasn't a great and i
didn't get a chance to rehearse with all
of them
i always liked it before the scenes you
know i would go into the trailers and
say let's talk through this scene let's
work it out
you know it's working out and i always
because of the
the work i did with brad barnes who
works at the uh
directing actors workshop he never let
the actors rehearse alone
so i take that into my practice too he
said because what happens is and i've
seen it
actors will end up creating motivations
and objectives for themselves
without you right as they work alone
and inevitably one actor may end up
directing the scene
like one actor may take charge so then
that may create some division on set
where one actor feels you know like
superior than another so he wants to
eliminate that
and he wants to eliminate the fact that
when you work when actors work up front
on the scene together they locked it so
then when they come to sit and it's
locked and you look at it and you're
like oh no
that's not it that's not it you know so
it may be good for them but it may not
serve you
as a storyteller as a director for the
overall picture
you know or maybe not even for that
particular scene so i don't like them to
work together
beforehand they can run lines but that's
it but don't start sitting there talking
about okay i'm gonna do this i'm gonna
do this and i'm
uh i'm gonna do that let the director
come in and do that and shape the scene
what are the biggest lessons making this
film is taught to you wow
hindsight is 20 20.
um
well you know it's always it's always
difficult to look back
on your work and talk about what you
could have did or what you should have
did
uh but there were some different choices
i would have probably made
with the script looking back on it now
i'm going to get too specific about that
because i want people to enjoy the movie
and i don't want to talk about maybe if
this was five years and the movie was
removed
then we could talk about it but now it's
so fresh i want people to go into the
movie and
be thinking oh this that any other but
there are probably some different
choices
um i could have made script wise
um ano another big lesson
is trust your gut yeah
trust your gut yeah no i yeah and i
and that just goes down to hiring crew
uh when you're all set making decisions
around shots
you know because sometimes what happens
on the film set people
you know everybody's there to make the
film right and everybody's there to uh
have a good experience in making it but
for some of us at the end of the day
they just want to go home
right and also their level of investment
sometimes it's just like
you know they just if you say we're
going to rap at 12 they're like oh let's
go home
you know what i mean and so you you may
get one shot in the scene and say let's
rap at 12. so
just to really trust yourself and you
got to hold to your guns
and sometimes that means being um
no we don't have it you know we got to
we we need to
we got to keep working and we got to
keep and i did that a few times with the
scene because
i'm not one to shoot a bad scene and so
if the scene is not working and i've
done that i had to shut the scene i had
to shut this
to set down one time we were at dukko's
house and um
the dialogue wasn't working i put the
scene up
and it was not working and i could tell
sometimes you can tell if it's the
dialogue or if it's the actors
delivery or it's the scene itself it's
lacking something
right in terms of um a point of view but
the dialogue wasn't working it was just
not working because
when we when steve had wrote it and i
worked with him on you know in terms of
the direction of the script
it was it was slow but then when we shot
it it was an act it was it was an action
but dukko had held a gun up it moved
fast
the scene was moving really fast so all
the words that he was saying and that
she was saying back it just didn't work
right and so i had to shut down the
scene and i told everybody
take five take ten minutes you know just
take ten minutes
and we're under the clock we're
constantly under the clock as we're
shooting right
and so you wanna do these kind of things
beforehand but we didn't have a chance
to rehearse this
ahead of time so i had to kind of
rehearse it on set and then when we
played the scene i was like this isn't
working
and the actors knew it wasn't working
that's that's the
that's sort of the best part about it
too is that actors know it's not working
right
and they're seeing if you know it's not
working and so if it's not working you
got to fix it
so i pulled everybody off set we went
into another room and i started to
rewrite the scene
right then there okay boom that works
boom that works okay boom look take that
away
run it again boom that doesn't work okay
say this okay boom let's put you here
all right you know and the actors have
already done their work focus
intention what i want from the scene the
objective they've done that right
so but then it may be honing that
objective more
right or it may mean in this case we
gotta you know
we don't need you to say nothing just
feel it
and it registers right and so we did
that and then when i put the scene up
it's magic it was magic i think the
actors were proud of it i was proud of
it i mean
and the crew was because the crew was
proud too because ultimately nobody
wants to shoot
garbage you know i mean like they don't
i mean you can put people in front of
the camera you can put a director there
but if you're shooting it i've been on
enough sets too
where if it's just bad it's like uh it's
bad
you know we don't want to shoot that it
doesn't do anything for anybody
so but you know i learned to you know i
learned to trust myself in those
situations
i learned to trust myself and then do
what it do what it takes to
to make the scene work